F
THIS MONEY.
SEAN?
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
ALL THAT CHAOS ON CAPITOL HILL
IS JUST THE LATEST CRISIS FACING
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
JOE'S RECORD OF FAILURE IS
STARTING TO CATCH UP WITH HIM IN
THE POLLS.
NOT ONLY IS HE UNDERWATER ON
APPROVAL UNDER THE LATEST PEW
RESEARCH POLL BUT THE MAJORITY
OF RESPONDENTS 56%.
THEY THINK JOE BIDEN IS NOT
MENTALLY SHARP.
BY THE WAY, I DO KNOW WHO THE
OTHER 40% CORPORATE OR WHAT YOU
ARE THINKING.
THE VACCINE MANDATES THAT BIDEN
IS SO EAGER TO OPPOSE ON
EVERYONE.
THEY COULD HAVE DISASTROUS
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE PREPARING TO CALL UP
THE NATIONAL GUARD THE BUILDING
FOR THE HOSPITAL RECORDS.
YOU KNOW, THE ONES IN MARCH AND
APRIL AND MAY OF 2020 IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE COVID SHIP SHOW OF
ALL SHIP SHOWS.
THINK OF FIRING THEM AND JUMPED
ON COVID GRENADES EVERY DAY TO
SAVE THE LIVES OF THEIR FELLOW
CITIZENS THAT THEY ARE ALL ABOUT
TO BE FIRED FOR REFUSING TO GET
THE VACCINE.
IT SOUNDS LIKE BIDEN COULD HAVE
YET ANOTHER CRISIS OF HIS OWN
MAKING ON HIS HANDS BEFORE HE
EVEN KNOWS IT.
YEAR WITH REACTION AUTHOR OF
"BEYOND BIDEN, REBUILDING THE
AMERICA WE LOVE," I CAN HOPE AND
PRAY.
WELL-WRITTEN BOOK.
I HAVE MY COPY.
THANK YOU, MR. SPEAKER.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR NEWT
GINGRICH.
WE GOT TO GET YAWNED BIDEN.
WE NEVER ABANDONED AMERICANS.
GIVING UP ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.
YOU SEE THE MESS AT THE BORDER
PREGNANCY INFLATION.
MY QUESTION IS, YOU SEE THAT
CYCLE ACTUALLY.
>> Reporter: GOING ON WITH THE
SQUAD VERSUS SO-CALLED
MODERATES.
WHO WINS?
>> AT -- I THINK THE COUNTRY IS
LOSING.
AND VERY FEW EXCEPTIONS.
MAYBE MENTION ANTHONY MATT.
THERE ARE NOT REALLY ANY
MODERATES IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
WHEN PUSH CAME TO THE CHEF IN
AUGUST, EVERY SINGLE DEMOCRATS
IN THE SENATE EVERY SINGLE
DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE VOTED FOR
A BIG SOCIALIST BILL THAT BIG
GOVERNMENT SOCIALIST BILL THAT
BERNIE SANDERS ROAD.
HOW CAN YOU HAVE A CLEAR
MESSAGE?
THEM TO HAVE AN OPEN SOCIALIST
RIGHT -- BY THE WAY, PROBABLY
SCORES A 5 TRILLION NOW THREE
AND A HALF TRILLION.
$3 TRILLION IN TAX INCREASES.
HIRES 85,000 NEW IRS AGENTS TO
HARASS TAXPAYERS.
APPARENTLY, ACCORDING TO ONE
READING, IT PROVIDES FOR FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
SO ALL THESE PEOPLE AT THE
BORDER.
THEY WILL GET TO GO TO COLLEGE.
AT THE TAXPAYERS POCKET
EXPENSES.
NOTHING IS FREE.
THAT MEANS IT IS A TAXPAYER
PROVIDED COLLEGE.
IT IS A TAXPAYER PROVIDED
HEALTHCARE.
AND SO TO I THINK THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE A FASCINATING WEEK.
PELOSI HAS BEEN VERY TOUGH.
SHE RUNS EIGHT DICTATORSHIP.
SHE HAS BEEN TWISTING ARMS.
SHE IS NOW STARTING TO BREAK
THEM.
THE PRESIDENT WILL START NEED
CAPPING PEOPLE.
>> Sean: IT SEEMS LIKE THE
SQUAD IS ZANE, IT IS OUR WAY OR
THE HIGHWAY.
AND THEY HAVE CONTROL OVER HER
SPEAKERSHIP.
>> THEY ARE ONLY DOING IT IN THE
SENSE THAT SHE HAS ENOUGH VOTES.
BUT LOOK AT WHAT THEY HAVE DONE.
FOR THE LAST YEAR, THEY HAVE
DECIDED EVERYTHING BY
THEMSELVES.
IN FACT, THEY EVEN REACHED OVER
AND KICKED A REPUBLICAN OFF THE
COMMITTEE, SOMETHING THAT HAS
NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE.
THEY CREATED AN INVESTIGATING
COMMITTEE AND THEY CONTROL THE
APPOINTEES.
NOW THEY TURN LIKE HAVING
SOMEBODY BECAUSE YOUR TEENAGE
SON OR DAUGHTER HAD RUN OFF WITH
A CREDIT CARD CLICK AROUND AND
CHARGED EVERYTHING.
BOB SCHIEFFER ARE IN THE BOUGHT,
YOU KNOW, A ROUND-TRIP AIRLINE
TICKET.
THEY SHOWED UP ONE MORNING AND
SAID, G, BACK AT WHAT WOULD YOU
PAY ALL OF MY BILLS?
AND THAT IS WHAT THAT WAS
PUBLICANS ARE SAYING.
WE ARE NOT PART OF THIS.
WE WERE NOT IN ON THE TAKE OFF.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE ON THE
LANDING.
AND THE DEMOCRATS HAVE MADE NO
EFFORT TO REACH OUT TO THE
REPUBLICANS AND ACTUALLY TRIED
TO THE SHARE POWER.
>> Sean: HERE'S MY QUESTION,
THOUGH.
>> SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Sean: I DON'T THINK ANY
REPUBLICANS SHOULD VOTE TO
INCREASE THE DEBT CEILING.
THEY HAVE TO HOUSE.
THEY HAVE DISSENTED.
THEY WANT TO SPEND ALL OF THIS
MONEY.
REPUBLICANS DON'T.
I DON'T THINK ONE REPUBLICAN
SHOULD VOTE TO INCREASE IT BY A
PENNY PICNIC AT DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING TO SICK-OUTS YOU ARE GOING
TO SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT?
IT IS GOING TO BE INSTINCT.
THAT IS NOT TYPICALLY HAVE
CONTROL OF CONGRESS.
THEY GET TO DECIDE.
SO IT WILL BE UP TO THEM WHETHER
OR NOT THEY RAISE THE DEBT
CEILING.
CORRECT?
>> YET BECOMING, YOU KNOW, IF I
WERE THE REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP,
I WOULD SAY, LOOK AT YOU CAN GET
OUR VOTES.
DROPPED A $5 TRILLION SPENDING
BILL.
DROP THE $3 TRILLION TAX
INCREASE.
DROP THE IDEA OF 85,000 NEW IRS
AGENTS.
YOU KNOW, WANT TO TALK ABOUT
HELPING YOU?
WELL, THIS IS WHAT IT IS GOING
TO COST FOR US TO DECIDE TO HELP
YOU.
AND IF YOU DON'T WANT TO MEET US
AND NEGOTIATE, WHY WOULD WE GIVE
YOU OUR VOTES?
I MEAN, KNOW REPUBLICAN SHOULD
VOTE FOR THE DEBT CEILING
INCREASE.
THAT IS THE DEMOCRATS' PROBLEM.
IT IS THEIR DISASTER.
AND FRANKLY, IF THEY KEEP
PUTTING POISON PILLS INTO THE
RESOLUTION NO REPUBLICAN SHOULD
VOTE FOR THE CONTINUING
RESOLUTION.
[OVERLAPPING SPEAKERS]
>> Sean: YOU HAVE A GREAT
PULSE OF HOW THINGS ARE WORKING
IN DC.
IT SEEMS LIKE DEMOCRATS, THE
CIVIL WAR IS GOING ON.
WHAT HAPPENS IN THE HOUSE?
WILL MENTION AND CINEMA HOLD THE
LINE.
I THINK ULTIMATELY, THEIR ARMS
ARE GOING TO BE TWISTED SO HARD
THEY WILL BE TWISTED OUT OF
THEIR SOCKETS TO GET THEIR
VOTES.
>> I THINK THEY HAVE A HARD TIME
DOING THAT.
THEY ARE OFFERING A BILL THAT
WOULD DESTROY WEST VIRGINIA'S
ECONOMY TOTALLY.
THEY ARE OFFERING IDEAS THAT ARE
DEEPLY OPPOSED IN ARIZONA.
ONLY 16% SUPPORT PART ONE OUT OF
EVERY SIX AMERICANS.
NOW, IT MAY BE THAT THE LEMMING
IS A PLACES -- REPLACING THE
DONKEY AS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
SYMBOL.
BUT I THINK THIS IS GOING TO BE
VERY UNPOPULAR IN THE COUNTRY.
AND MY GUESS IS THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO GET IT THROUGH BECAUSE
IN THE END, THEY CAN'T SATISFY
THOSE WHO ARE NOT MODERATES.
BUT THEY WANT TO SURVIVE.
AND THOSE WHO ARE RETICLES IN
DISTRICTS WHERE IT DOES NOT
MATTER.
I THINK IT IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
JOB FOR PELOSI.
>> Sean: DID YOU EVER THINK
YOU WOULD GET THIS MEDICAL?
>> NO.
>> Sean: DID YOU EVER THINK WE
WOULD HAVE THAT KIND OF CHAOS AT
THE BORDER?
DID YOU EVER THINK WE WOULD BE
BEGGING OPEC AFTER WE'VE FINALLY
ACHIEVED ENERGY INDEPENDENCE TO
PRODUCE MORE OIL, AND HE TURNED
US DOWN.
PRETTY EMBARRASSING THAT
MR. SPEAKER.
>> LOOK, I THINK YOU ARE VERY
SWIFT.
THE WEIRDEST POLITICAL COALITION
IN MODERN AMERICAN HISTORY.
I THINK THEY ARE TOTALLY OUT OF
TOUCH WITH REALITY.
I THINK THE DAMAGE THEY ARE
DOING IS UNIMAGINABLE.
AND I REALLY WORRY THAT THESE
GUYS, STUMBLE INTO A BIG WAR,
NOT A SMALL OR.
I WORRY PARTICULARLY ABOUT
CHINA.
THE CHINESE DICTATORSHIP HAS TO
BE LOOKING AT THIS KIOSK AND
THINKING, THIS GUY IS OLD.
HE IS WEAK.
HE IS CONFUSED.
>> Sean: AND THOSE DONALD
TRUMP TWEETS THAT EVERYONE IN
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA
CHARACTERIZED AS MAN SEEM PRETTY
APPEALING RIGHT NOW BECAUSE HE
ACTUALLY, HE INSTILLED FEAR IN
OTHER COUNTRIES AND HE ACTUALLY,
US TO ENERGY INDEPENDENCE,
CONTROLLED T